our investigators determined that the
crossfire hurricane investigators did
not and could not corroborate any of the
substantive allegations contained in the
steel reporting not not was still able
to nor was still able to produce
corroboration for any of the reported
allegations even after being offered one
million or more by the FBI for such
corroboration the report reads later it
goes further to say that the information
was known to be rumor and speculation
Democrats planted fake evidence and then
used it against Trump in order to
justify their assumptions about his
guilt the FBI used that for probable
cause to further an investigation
without any basis at all within days of
their receipt the report reads the
unvetted and unverified steel reports
were used to support probable cause in
the FBI's fisa applications targeting
page a U.S citizen who for a period of
time had been an advisor to Trump as
discussed later in the report this was
done at a time when the FBI knew that
the same information steel had provided
to the FBI had also been fed to the
media and others in Washington